The Joe Rogan experience.
What I think is interesting is that
the continual buyers along that
technological path is towards profit.
You know,
when we see those machines,
the end point is always how do we make,
how do we maximize profit?
There is no like the influence
of how do we do what's right.
That's that sort of a a person like
a sort of a general effort call.
Uh, what do I want to say? Sort
of code is not being introduced.
There is no regulation. Like,
you know, ultimately, you know,
ultimately people will create the
warrior monkeys or the most profitable
machines people because the
counter argument isn't being made.
No one is like what I'm saying now
it's making it there. There's just,
there's no union of uh, you know,
there's no sort of clear opinion of,
hang on a minute, where
could we be going? No,
there is no body or ideology that's
able to oppose the relentless march of
capitalism. I'm not sort of like
a flower. Capitalism is bad.
Here I am promoting a book using or
an iPhone or you know what I mean?
We're all swimming in it.
Right?
But what I'm saying is that if we
acknowledge there are transcendent realms,
there is information and data that exists
beyond what we're able to receive with
our senses. How are we going to
incorporate that in the way we organize?
Cause otherwise this off the magnetism,
the Paul the g force of
what's most profitable,
what's going to continue to suit the uh,
requirements of the
powerful that will always,
the bias will always
fall in that direction.
And it seems like where that's heading
is certain kinds of ecological disaster,
certain kinds of economic inequality,
certain kinds of conflict, you know,
and like we're not, one of them
are, they're simple. Uh, uh,
experiments that I apply is, you know, if
we're, you know, if when people say, oh,
what's wrong with the world
world's I fucked all this polarity,
I sometimes think, well who is
benefiting from how it is now? Are there,
is anyone benefiting?
Are there any groups,
institutions or individuals for whom
this current state is beneficial?
And if the answer to that question is yes,
then look at who those institutions are.
And they are most likely to a degree
involved in establishing and maintaining
these systems. And there are, you know,
institutions and individuals
and organizations that
this works just fine for
they just capitalizing on it or are they
organizing it and is a normal part of
the way human beings operate with
this constant desire for innovation,
constant desire for improvement.
We always want to push further. No,
no one's comfortable where they are.
They will always want
to be in a better place.
And this is almost like it's
built into capitalism, right?
I agree that this materialism,
which is built into capitalism also is
what fuels innovation because you want
the newest iPhone so they have to
design it and build it and make it,
and when new things come out,
like this new robot that apparently
you're gonna hundred models,
whatever that means. What that is
is this is they're going to sell it.
So there's like,
it's fueling innovation.
Someone else will come along and compete
with Boston dynamics. Then there'll be,
there'll be innovation wars.
If these innovation wars
weren't in place right now,
our phones would look nothing like
the iPhone 10 it just wouldn't,
it wouldn't look like the
Esx it would look like,
who knows where it would look like.
But there would be no,
no incentive for them to compete against
all these Samsung devices and Huawei
devices and all that stuff
is fueling this innovation.
But it's all being fueled by capitalism.
You're quite right that that is the
innovation is one of the benefits of the
maintaining this system.
But it seems to me that we are excluding
other factors like that that recur
throughout human cultures.
We all have an idea of fairness of justice
and yeah, I don't want some clunky,
weird sort of eastern bloc
phone made out of gray plastic.
Only one button on it. Yeah.
But like we have to I suppose,
examine as a society and as individuals
what is important to us now where I
think, you know, we've talked,
touched several times upon the fact that
as an individual you're more likely to
bias yourself towards
negative information online.
You know like we do have a degree
of individual power and individual
responsibility and I feel like if enough
people awaken to the possibility of
different narratives that the capitalist
idea of innovation and success and
progress that that all of these words can
be examined. What do you mean progress?
That assumes a teleology,
a purpose, a destination.
If all time is happening at once,
if space is infinite,
like you know that bit of yours of light
unit to try and fathom for a moment the
limitlessness that were existing within,
then all these things are constructs.
This is a construct and it
is good to have technology,
but it's possible to like at points in
times of crisis such as what it feels
like we're at now. Now though
that people have said, oh,
we always feel that every generation
thinks that they're the one because they
know their own impending death is
coming and they narrativize that into
something social and global regardless.
There's got to be a time where we start
to introduce different ideas into our
systems. It seems like there's room for
that now because we do live in a toe,
a truly global culture that there is the
possibility for mono lifts to introduce
new innovation and there is nothing
that can oppose it or regulate it.
We started to see this kind of breakdown,
so I'm interested in how we can
individually prepare ourselves to organize
society differently to be able to overcome
pretty superficial differences like,
oh you go hunting and I don't go hunt in.
We ain't really gives a fuck.
They start talking about how we can
organize a size where people who go on and
it'll don't go hunting can live
peacefully in different ways.
Not entirely governed by a small cabal.
You know,
and I'm sure plat power
is more complex than that,
that seem to be hugely biasing the
direction of this so called program.
I think you answered your own previous
questions when you're talking about
whether or not you can be spiritual
and funny and like what are you doing?
Can you carve that path out for yourself?
That what you're there by explaining
that would influence people would give
people a perspective that
allows them to say, yeah,
like why are we doing this and
what is the purpose of this?
And if enough people hear those words
and have that perspective introduced to
them, it'll change the way
they interact with the world.
And that changes the world.
It really does.
And that's one of the more powerful
things about discussions when someone like
you says something like that and it
resonates with people and they start
thinking like, why am I living like
this? Like what if I'm only have,
if I really do only have 50 years to live,
why am I living these 50 years in some
really unproductive bullshit way that's
not satisfying at all? Cause I just
want a bigger house. Like what is it?
Do I want a faster car? Do I want
to have expensive piece of jewelry?
Like what is,
what is the purpose of this path that
I'm on now versus a path that I could be
on?
And what is the real conflict that we
all experienced between each other?
Is it? How much of it is due
to a lack of communication?
How much of is due to a lack of
real listening and understanding.